well I was around for the creation of
the gold ETF and you know what the
narrative was at the time it was you
know this capital is going to come into
this space but the day-to-day trading
volumes of gold are actually not large
enough to sustain that kind of capital
inflow you know what happened the daily
trading volumes of gold went through the
roof we did a research and we said okay
we think we know the price elastic
response to inflows to the price of
Bitcoin and so you know we modeled what
we reasonably thought the inflows would
be so you multiply the Clos by the price
elastic response and you end up with a
price and that price I think came out to
between $15 and
$140,000 this is just math now what's
the causality
there all right guys bang bang I've got
Danny here with me uh Danny last time we
talked about two years ago A lot's
happened since then uh prices went up a
lot then they went down a lot seem to be
recovering how do you evaluate maybe
from the top of the 2021 bull market to
today what's happened and more more
importantly why it's
happened well great to see you again p
and um yeah it's been uh two years since
we l spoke and uh it seems like an
awfully long time U but a lot has
happened so I guess we've probably been
both occupied with the uh with the
developments in the
marketplace um like me you've been
through multiple crypto Cycles believe
it or not this is my uh 11th year in the
crypto
industry um and you know the industry
has changed Ed you know in a dramatic
way over that period of time um as I
first recall it was populated almost
exclusively by computer scientists and
startups called you know blockchain.com
and coinbase uh and we've come a long
long way since
then you know I I think at the the coin
shares level you know our our approach
and and we can get into the company I
think a little bit later but our
approach was to build something very
solid very robust something which would
be fit for a public market you know at
the top to end of the listing spectrum
and accordingly you know we built our
business quite slowly um and carefully
and we have no choice but some of our
peers and competitors built their
businesses extremely rapidly and as you
will well know and our audience will
well know we saw a dramatic rise and
fall uh for companies like bitb um for
companies like um Celsius three arrows
you know the list is very very very long
and those companies were both you know
very fortunate to grow as rapidly as
they did um but as we were going through
that period of extremely rapid growth of
those companies my impression certainly
was they were running a little bit too
fast and I don't think that governance
was there I don't think the risk
management was there uh I heard some
extraordinary stories about you know
people extending credit that no one in
their right mind would extend all looks
great in the bull market but then you
know you have the inevitable unwinding
and um I actually posted something on my
LinkedIn uh at the bottom of the market
pretty much as soon as SPF was was
arrested and that was you know the low
in Psychology it was everybody was not
just forc liquidated that was liquidated
then there was a sort of a delayed
reaction where it wasn't you going bust
it was your counterparty going bust that
made you go
bust and the sentiment just became
maximum negative and you know that the
low of the move 16k or something like
that basis Bitcoin I have seen this
multiple times you know in my career on
Wall Street where uh there's been a
cycle and it happened in oil it happened
in natural gas it happened in Copper um
and the similarities were incredible
there was always you know the big Market
leading company it would have been
canatu in Copper it would have been
metal gazelle shaft in energy it would
have been Enron in natural gas it would
been Brian hunter in in the natural gas
hedge fund
business very big dominant company um
you know read FTX for that and maybe a
couple of others there was a poster Char
spokesman for that company all the names
that we we now know in in
infamy and and when those people you
know ran out of Road and the market
began to sense they were vulnerable and
people all exited the ship uh and they
sank in every case and were arrested in
many cases and jailed in some cases
that always represented the cycle low
and in each of those examples I just
quoted yeah that it represented the
multi-year cycle low of the asset class
so you know going back to you know the S
SPF uh collapse uh we were talking 16k
Bitcoin that was the wrong price given
everything it was the wrong price there
it was a Victory lap for the haters
there was forc liquidation left right
and Center there was knock on effects
from third party exposures that other
people and um it was the wrong price so
we had a something of a recovery call it
to the you know low 20s mid
20s and then some other interesting
stuff happened where there were a series
of enforcement actions you know largely
by the SEC but not limited to the SEC
and I think those in in the initial
phases had very negative impacts on
price you'd see the latest lawsuit and
the market would be down you know $1,000
$2,000 on the back of it and as a market
Watcher myself and again having been
through these Cycles in other
Commodities what you're really looking
for is the time when those pieces of
news no longer move the market and the
market then sort of becomes immune uh
and impervious to that kind of news and
you need to see that because in any
investment you really need to know you
know where the bottom is you know it
might be a silty bottom but somewhere
roughly where the bottom is and when
that kind of news can be absorbed
without Market impact uh you know that
there's a little bit of a foundation
there so you know now we're in the mid
20s and you know we we don't really have
much of a catalyst I think it was very
instructive to look at a lot of private
company stocks not just ours but many
many others as interest rates you know
got very high uh to the 5 six 7%
depending on which country you're
talking about the valuations and the mul
pools of all these private companies
collapsed and and you know in many cases
haven't sign L recovered and I think you
know Bitcoin is one of those kind of um
risk on assets probably arguably the
most risk on asset and therefore um
while we were sitting at 25 you know
having been too low at 19 we're sort of
battling this headwind of of really high
interest rates and and lack of
speculative capital and liquidity you
know shrinking and shrinking and
shrinking not just in the macro
environment but in the crypto
environment as well um and that was true
of counterparties going out of
businesses it was true of credit lines
that people were offering and could
receive and so on and then all of a
sudden you know following July you know
July was kind of you know crept up to
near 30 following that you know two
things start to happen you started to
see a little bit of a initially in
the energy price which took some of the
heat out of inflation because the you
know Russia Ukraine Spike started to
kind of wear off then you sort of saw a
little bit of backing up in inflation as
well all of a sudden we're not sitting
here thinking rates are going to God
knows what number um we're thinking
actually the worst might be over that's
good for another little bump you still
don't really have a catalyst at that
point okay you just TR to try of avoid
the bullets as it were and um the
capitalist was really I think um you
know let's call it broadly institutional
interest in crypto something that we've
been after for a long time you know you
had a Confluence of a number of events
we've got some forward process forward
progress in in regulation in Europe
through the mic legislation makes some
sense you know Switzerland's still a
very solid jurisdiction the UK is a
little bit sort of uh negative generally
with crypto but trying to make steps to
go forward in fact if you listen to the
politicians sounds a lot better than it
actually is when you talk to the
regulator but moving in the right
direction and so that started to look a
little bit better rate start to look a
little bit softer and then we have some
tangible input you know the Black Rock
ETF and I think that was you know that
was the capitalist to to really move
this and what it's saying is okay we've
kind of exited all the Bad actors uh
we've put at least the seeds of a
regulatory framework in Europe in place
and outside of America um and that's a
base on which you can build and I think
that is a legitimate Catalyst I think
the impact of that kind of thing um
people need to understand that when
Black Rock has a product black has three
trillion of assets that they can deploy
their clients can make a 10 basis point
allocation to bitcoin that's a huge
number and those clients probably
wouldn't buy something outside of that
environment because you know they deal
with the biggest and the best clients in
the world so that I you know that I
think is where we are and that that I
think now continues because you know
another thing I learned about markets
over a long period of time is when there
is an event horizon and the Event
Horizon in this case is the approval of
such an ETF um the market tends to move
into that vacuum while it's happening
that's why I'm not really in a hurry for
a judgment i' kind of like to see this
dragon all all next year would be just
fine because I think the anticipation of
that is a positive and um and also you
know we're seeing for the first time I
would say um you know institutional
interest in to be involved in the
marketplace from really Quality
Companies who make want us to White
Label products may want to buy our
products for the first time you know we
we're seeing and it almost seems to me
like you know these institutions are
going right we had a big backup in price
we had a big clean out of of Bad actors
we've got some regulatory framework
which we can kind of hang our hat on
we've clearly got the client demand
Larry think will tell you that directly
and so we're going to try and get
involved and um hey this is this is what
you know you and I have been sitting
around waiting for for many years and I
I truly believe that is happening as we
speak how impactful if we kind of look
forward maybe the next two to three five
years how impactful can this be and I'll
give you kind of a couple of things I've
been thinking about I don't yet have
kind of a strong opinion about right one
is if somebody wanted Bitcoin badly
enough they probably went and figured
out a way to get it is one argument uh a
second one is even if the ETFs gathered
50 billion in assets it's an 850 900
billion dollar asset and so how much
could you really you know it's not like
it's going to Triple overnight another
argument is no this is the signal that
everyone gets in right every asset
manager nation state it's kind of it it
is this time is different and and
there's uh the breakout of this kind of
four-year cycle and and kind of having
process where do you sit and and how are
you thinking about this right now
today's episode is brought to you by
trust and will I've gone through a
number of different changes in my life
over the last few years I got married I
had a kid and I had to start thinking
about how could I ensure that my wife
and my child would be okay if anything
ever happened to me that's where trust
wills and estate planning come into play
now most people what they do is they get
introduced to a friend an uncle or
someone in their local community it
tends to be someone who's really
expensive a lawyer an accountant or
somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one- siiz
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as $159 which allows you to now
protect your legacy from the comfort of
your own home leverage their excellent
customer support available via phone
email or chat they have thousands of
five star reviews and a rating of
excellent on trust pilot it takes most
people 20 to 30 minutes to complete
their estate plan with trust and will
and not only that but if you go to
trustand will.com pomp you'll get 10%
off plus you'll get free shipping of all
your estate planning documents so go to
trustand will.com Pomp and make sure you
get an estate plan in place whether it's
for you or one of your loved ones having
a trust Andor a will can literally be
the difference between someone being
taken care of and someone not go check
them out today at trustand will.com pomp
well I was around for the creation of
the gold ETF in the beginning and and to
date myself um and you know what the
narrative was at the time it was okay
you know this capital is in theory going
to come into this space but the
day-to-day trading volumes of gold are
actually not large enough to sustain
that kind of capital inflow you know
what happened the daily trading volumes
of gold went through the roof and and
you know when we at coin shares and I'm
not sure how publicly available this
research is you might have to call James
butterfill our head of research and ask
him nicely uh if any viewers are
interested it could be on our website
I'm not absolutely sure we we did a you
know we we lead the industry in terms of
providing data on institutional flows
into crypto and so we have some very
granular data on that and we we did a
research on our own and we said okay we
think we know the price elastic response
to inflows to the price of Bitcoin we
can correlate that back over time um
half our marketing and research team by
the way came from the gold business
funny enough because we hired them from
uh Wisdom Tree uh actually to come to
the crypto industry and so they're very
familiar with that whole um that whole
uh development back in in the gold ETF
beginning
and so you know we modeled what we
reasonably thought the inflows would be
so you multiply the inflows by the price
elastic response if you end up with a
price and that price I think came out to
between $15 and
$140,000 now I have never in my entire
crypto career been the guy saying the
moon and 500k and you know all that kind
of rubbish but this is just math right
this is just like a reasonable
assumption for these kind of inflows
moves it that way
now what's the causality there you can't
just say that the creation of a gold ETF
and the inflow of institutional clients
who wouldn't have otherwise invested in
gold was the only Factor because once
they start doing it the retail starts
doing it as well so so I do think that
um it will be you know maybe the type of
people you mention in your first comment
those who figured out how to do it first
it's probably where we are right now
second you know you get the actual
announcement there's maybe a little
profit taking usually the rumor by the
rumor sell the fact thing is a is a is a
good strategy to trade uh and after that
you're sitting there waiting for inflows
to come into the into the actual ETF and
and I think that will be a real driver
um happened also in the silver ETF which
came after the Gold ETF and Barclays who
used to own the silver ETF before they
had the problems in 2008 and had to sell
it to Black Rock
um used to publish a very useful
spreadsheet showing you how much silver
had been accumulated into the ETF week
by week by week and after six months of
this you could draw a line through it
and kind of go there's not enough silver
and silver reacted you know accordingly
so so yeah I think it's real and I think
it starts with the guys that can already
do it it's followed by the institutions
and then it's followed by the retail
guys who probably got a little bit burnt
you know in a couple of the dips um
particularly in 21 um but it's it's a
green light across the board I
think now when we look at um what is
happening now there's some people who
are front running Federal Reserve
potentially moving back towards loose
monetary policy cutting rates you know
cut the whole narrative that I think
people are grabbing on to how important
is the Federal Reserve for the movement
of bitcoin's price and um on one hand we
see these like you know Bitcoin over
global M2 Supply on the other hand we
see the FED still committed to
destroying investor demand and bitcoin's
up you know 150% uh on the year and it
seems like you know could care less what
drone Powell says in his press
conferences I think it makes a huge
impact um you know it's just looser
credit you know Bitcoin is a very
responsive act uh uh asset class um to
looser credit um I'm surprised it didn't
do a little bit better under the
inflationary kind of regime um but you
know for all those who said oh it was
disappointing that Bitcoin didn't rally
more you know during the inflationary
cycle because Bitcoin had been touted as
an inflationary
asset well we didn't really know that
because because um we' never seen an
inflation recycle before in the history
of Bitcoin it was too uh too young so I
think you know what we've learned and we
do keep learning as time goes by about
how Bitcoin responds um to me it is it
is it is a risk on asset you know backed
by some technology Tailwind that that
slowly kind of permeates it out amongst
you know many many more users as you can
see from you know wallet adoption and
the amount of Bitcoin in wallets it just
diffuses out into space continually over
time um so yeah I do think that the look
we're clearly on the shallow you know
beginnings of a Down cycle in rates um
and you know the the FED has not done a
great job of reducing the size of the
balance sheet to date neither of any
other central banks um not quite sure
how good they're ever going to be at
doing that and you know as Cycles happen
maybe we'll do some more money printing
at some point in time so so I think
there's you know a modest tail when all
other things being equal um and as you
know as we see failure to reduce the
balance sheets and and arguably in some
extraneous circumstance more money
printing it seems to be unavoidable over
time physically unavoidable um then then
you know we start we ratch it higher
still so you know look this is not a
crazy bull market like it's going to be
up $110,000 in a day as it has been you
know from time to time in the past I
think it's a really broad based or
potentially broad-based and very solid
rally that could go on for some
time now coin shares I think is very
interesting business because you
basically have exposure to different
parts of the market right you I've seen
reports that say hey look at their
principal investing they're fantastic
investors there's others that say wow
this Asset Management business uh is
going to do really well as prices go up
um there's even been uh some coverage I
think from some of the research analysts
that are like coin shares benefits When
eth goes to uh proof of stake right
there's just kind of all kinds of
different things being written or
covered about the business how do you
think about coin shares and like when
when you think of okay this is the
business we have today how do you
describe it to people yeah um well two
ways to describe it really it's it's one
what do we do from a qualitative
perspective and two you know how do our
earnings actually you know respond to
different market conditions
um so if I had to describe it in a few
words it's an asset management business
um we currently have around 4 billion
and we have it in a wide array of
products now um we have our Legacy xbt
provider products in Sweden which
incredibly popular from the day they
listed um we have coin digital
Securities which is a a platform um of a
different kind it's a little bit more
institutionally focused a little bit
more institutionally structured a little
bit cheaper uh fee wise U multiple
products there and multiple listings on
different exchanges you know for those
multiple products we have a couple of um
private trading fund funds run by chap
The Works Russ called Lewis fellas um
that do relatively sophisticated you
know Bitcoin and E strategies for you
know highet worth in private and
institutional investors we have an
equities fund the block index that we
joint ventured with
Invesco we have coin shares fund two
which is now four years old and is a
10year duration private Equity um fund
closed that run by Melton deas um so you
know a pretty wide spectrum of
investment product and you know You'
have seen the news recently that we are
involved with Valkyrie and we're hoping
to also be a player in the in the USC
ETF market now so quite a wide a wide
different array and it's it's been
really interesting to see how loyal
certain customers are to certain
geographies and certain structures they
know this ticker and I'm like that
ticker is cheaper and it's the same
exposure but they don't really move and
um and our our Capital base is very very
sticky and I'll tell you an interesting
fact which is of our of the assets that
we currently have I think we have given
back way more than the invested capital
that we ever received in other words
everybody in our Network on mass in some
is trading with house money and I've
never seen that before in an investment
product um and the truth you know one of
the one of the sort of unspoken truths
about the asset management business in
crypto is you never really raised that
much money you kind of got to have money
from three years ago that's multiplied
significantly and that's actually by far
the best source of fresh a
I mean the last month or two I think our
A's gone up by like $600 million and
that's purely you know there might be 10
20 50 100 million you know here or there
coming in or out but basically it's
because the asset class is going up so
that's where we are actually
synthetically quite long Bitcoin because
the more Bitcoin goes up the more I goes
up the more our fees go up very simple
and um that's a good exposure to have so
that's that the second part of the
business which has been
really evolving over
time just change it's changed so many
times actually over the years is coin
Shar Capital markets which is our Market
making business which was started back
in 2015 probably 2014 because no one
else would make markets in our
Securities because no one had the
Securities leg and the crypto leg
simultaneously the crypto guys and
securities guys but nobody did both so
we started that business um it's been
through a number of Cycles you know
broadly speaking we make markets in our
own products um and as as conditions
permit you know we'll make markets for
third parties um and we do an amount of
Arbitrage trading whether it's you know
Buy on this exchange sell on another one
buy a derivative that's underprice
versus another derivative that's
overpriced and you know no outright
exposure or stuff like that but you know
these days we're probably doing between
one and two billion a month in the peak
we're probably doing five billion a
month in that business
um it is represented over time anywhere
from 25 to 50% of our overall Revenue so
in some cases almost matches the fee
business that we have and um and what's
happened you know despite the fact that
volumes have gone down the competitive
landscape has shrunk by at least 50% and
so margins have gotten
higher and I don't think we're quite
where we were but it's not as bad as it
sounds when you talk about a 50% drop in
volume um it's uh you know the the the
the the money that can be made is is
actually um more than you know it's more
than that so and that that business it
sounds simple but you know you have to
set up all kinds of banking lines and
exchange facilities and and really be
able to actually operate it you know
manage the risk measure the risk and uh
and have the sort of liquidity and the
partners around that you need to to make
that work so you know that's that's
quite a mature business at this point
it's it's run quite professionally and
it's a big contributor um the third part
is as you say you know we have
investments in probably 40 companies if
you if you look at all of the pockets we
have um some of those are actually Side
Pockets some ex investors some pre IPO
investors that pretty much mirror the
current cap table um we have a fund with
that group we have a coin chest fund too
um we have um you know some stuff on the
balance some significant stuff on the
balance sheet as well and um and yeah
you know look those are generally you
know we've had a few losses like
everybody else a few writeoffs like
everybody else but you know dotted
around there are some real winners a
great example was block demon uh we had
a position in Block demon you know one
of 25 positions in coin Shar fund two
and we managed to return all of the
invested Capital to the investors by
selling a piece of that position um when
you know in 2021 which is obviously a
wise thing to do in retrospect so
there's been some good winners there and
you know more importantly than that
that's nice but more importantly we've
done lots of business with our
significant private Equity positions so
you know we do a lot of business with
Kimu our custodian that we launch with
Nur and Ledger we do a tremendous amount
of business with flow Bank in which
we're a big you know client um a big a
big shareholder um we've done a lot of
business with 3 IQ uh in Canada you know
issuing uh ETFs uh with Kingdom trust um
who have recently gone through a buyou
process which was a good deal for us so
and in all of those cases you know we
were either clients of theirs or created
and co-marketed products with them or
they became clients of ours and um and
and that's been um that's been you know
a good activity not nearly as impactful
as the trading and the investment
management business um but but we shall
you know we're still in the game you
know with a lot of those and see see
we'll see how they go the final point
I'll make and this is a new one so I
would said what I just said six months
ago the new one is is really in two
pieces there's money on the edge of
crypto that is either crypto money so
just to throw a couple of names you know
the bances the teas the you know the the
even dcgs arguably of the world and you
know these guys may in some cases not be
deemed experienced enough to operate a
regulated crypto business um that's kind
of a requirement in many many cases now
and you know if you don't have the track
record and you don't have the
infrastructure or you've made missteps
in the past it's very hard to obtain
those kind of licenses we have a lot of
licenses and um and you know they've
been hard hard for three four years to
get some of them and um and so we find
ourselves in a position where we can
actually form a buffer between
capital and regulated businesses where
those that Capital cannot directly
access and we'll find ways you know to
make that work you know within the
appropriate regulatory
framework the second thing uh that's
going on is you know there is there is a
a cohort of asset managers who can't
make it pay because believe it or not
you know and I've seen some examples of
this you know you can have a few hundred
million dollars in a crypto Asset
Management business and still not be
able to make it pay because of you know
relatively low fees and relatively High
regulatory costs and Staffing costs and
so there's an opportunity for us and you
know I think the valkyrie deal is
probably in that in that flavor where
you know we can bring our scale um we
can operate some of these businesses
very little incrementally and so there
was a rollup trade going on where um you
know the bigger managers can can take
out the smaller managers and that can be
on an outright purchase or on a buyout
or on a JV basis
um so and that's that's a new activity
you know and that that to me is US
finally getting paid for the goldplated
infrastructure that we spent so long
spent so much money on building now on
this part of um I'm gon to call it
there's like the systematic stuff right
where uh you either are passive in the
market or you're not making decisions
yourselves um versus what I'll call
maybe more of like the past uh in terms
of understanding macro understanding
markets making private
Investments how much of um crypto is
different maybe than let's say in the
traditional Financial system where uh
you know people see everyone from uh the
citadels all the way to the 72s to you
know even Doo and um um uh Bridgewater
like a lot of these folks I think have
really driven home this idea that like
the machines are making the decisions
we don't seem to see that much of it
obviously Market making maybe is a
little bit different than uh some of the
the private Investments and maybe
there's like the two extremes but how do
you think about like human intervention
versus machine software Ai and like this
rise of the Machines are smarter than
the
humans something something that's been a
you know a growing Trend throughout my
entire career um you know when I started
it was 100% humans and um that is
definitely not the case
anymore
in the company that predated coin shares
um the commodity fund um that me and a
couple of my partners ran we actually
ran both strategies we had a purely
Quant strategy and we had a purely
discretionary strategy and I ran the
discretionary strategy and one of my
partners run the Quant strategy and I
have to say I think they were very
complimentary and but the style could
not be more different um it's an
entirely different activity um um so you
know I don't think there's and even even
in the companies you just mentioned the
D shaes the citadels the all these you
know the the millenniums of the world um
you will find actually if you go below
the surface that both of those Styles
still exist the difference in when it
gets a little
bit let's say um uh what's the word a
camouflaged
is in execution you almost need an
algorithm these days like in my day you
pick up the phone and say you know buy a
th000 lots of crude oil and then someone
would scream onto the floor that you buy
a th000 lots of crude oil Nobody Does
that anymore so and the reason you need
alos is that there are so many other
alos that as soon as you put in an offer
someone's going to be ahead of your
offer be ahead of your offer and they're
going to they're going to gain you so so
you shouldn't really be confused that
that that in a way you might have a
stand driller sitting there going you
know I want to buy you know 100 million
of 10 years but he's not going to pick
up the phone to the Chicago mer and and
say those words he's going to give that
to Goldman or who whomsoever and they're
going to run a smart algo that's going
to do that and that it's just a cat
Mouse game you know there's no I don't
think there's any intellectual input
into that we run a ton of alos in coin
shares to do exactly that you know if we
get lifted on a market making offer
somehow there'll be some algo running on
how you're going to get that you know
that position back again um those Algos
are written by humans by the way not an
AI at least not yet
so so in a way you know you're just
really codifying what you would do if
you were sitting there and you could do
it that fast which you can't um but a
lot of the you know AR quants will sit
around and they will write those elos
but the logic behind those elos you know
would be no different to what a good
discretionary Trader would be doing and
executing an order so it's really what's
your strategy is is it a discretionary
strategy there's a place for that is it
a Quant strategy there's a place for
that but pretty much either way you're
executing with an
algo what are you most excited about
thematically in crypto so not like
products not coin share um you know in
terms of business lines but are there
certain themes or areas of the market
that you feel like uh are either under
you know um scrutinized at the moment
and will be bigger than people think or
maybe even areas that everyone's talking
about that you're less excited about and
think could be overhyped this episode is
brought to you by cal.com what do I have
in common with Chad Hurley from YouTube
Toby from Shopify and Alexis from 776
and the co-founder of Reddit we all use
cal.com instead of cly and we are all
early investors as well cal.com is
leading the charge of scheduling
Platforms in the open-source sphere
offering you the chance to harness the
efficiency previously reserved for leite
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open source technology than
cal.com is for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar
be efficient when scheduling and make
sure that no one can steal your time I
think the most interesting observation
pump has I never really
understood how there was room for the
proliferation of different crypto assets
that occurred you know for quite some
time uh I was active in crypto when
there was only Bitcoin and then I think
there might have been Litecoin and then
I think there might have been ethereum
but it seemed like a long time to get
like three cryptos and and we somehow
went from 3 to 20,000 in a very short
period of time and and what what I
realized finally was crypto is is you
know very very e very low hurdle of
Entry very high hurdle of
success um and it's been you know it's
been frustrating that you know I've been
involved with the tasos foundation for
some time now tasos is a great
blockchain a very secure very
sophisticated blockchain it's one of you
know in my view probably the top five in
terms of its its
functionality um but it is very very
tough to unseat bitcoin as a store of
value and ethereum as as as a as a
utility at this point and there are some
other promising you know candidates for
sure
but it just seems that you know the
longer time goes on the more the
infrastructure built around the Legacy
old Legacy coins um becomes more of a
factor for their longer term
survival and that makes sense in a way
because as we know Improvement Protocols
are there so that the community can
improve the the the network on which
they're working and if they're getting
an idea for the near protocol or the
advanced protocol um why not you know if
it's a good one bake it into you know
into ethereum so what I think what I
think I'm learning here is that I wasn't
sure how this would all unwind but it
does seem to me that you know there will
be some sort of darwinian Extinction of
a large number of cryptos and
unfortunately a lot of those cryptos are
the ones that you know the the
uninformed retail investors might have
piled into in 2020 and
2021 um you know some of them shocking
you know shocking in terms of
performance in 95% declines and stuff
like that and I think a lot of those
things are Walking Dead you know I think
we may be now reverting to you know a a
very limited number of meaningful crypto
networks and you know I think we just
need to sort of circle in around those
and kind of forget about a lot of this
other stuff and that you know that kind
of evolution doesn't happen in normal
financial markets in normal financial
markets things are built behind a wall
to last very robustly very inertly very
featur less and they'll be there for 20
years like my HSBC Bank account is
pretty much the same as it was 20 years
ago
um that's not the way crypto works and
so we had to find another creation
Extinction mechanism and I think that's
what we've been seeing so this may sound
boring but I'm most excited about
Bitcoin and ethereum for those reasons I
I think that uh majority of the market
probably feels exactly the same way um
another question I have is you've been
doing this for 10 11 years now uh when
you first did it you've told me a lot of
your peers kind of looked at you like
hey Danny you okay what are you
doing a decade later uh have they
capitulated what what are some of your
peers doing what are they saying behind
closed doors I think what my and I'm
talking about my peers outside you know
my financial Market peers okay not not
my you know not my inside crypto uh kind
of peers but but yeah there are a cycle
or two behind me you know they'll get
there when you know you come to realize
that you know there's a particular kind
kind of heartbeat to crypto um that is
more volatile than other asset classes
and you know just because you lost 40%
on your last purchase uh and might have
been ill disciplined in how to deal with
that potentially um you will learn and
and you know I felt like you know post
2021 there a lot of my kind of outside
crypto Network um kind of gave up on it
like oh you know that's done you know
that's over and now all of a sudden like
my doctor called me up and like talking
to me about do I like Bitcoin more
ethereum and how do I you know get
involved you know in this current
Marketplace and I want to hold my own
keys so I don't have exchange risk and
so they're coming back now no doubt
about that and it's always when my
phone's ringing with those kind of
people that you know you realize you're
in a different cycle and and I suffered
the same thing I mean my first exposure
to bitcoin I bought it at 100 it went to
a th000 over the course of a year and
then it went to 80 and my reaction was
well that was fun but it's over right
it's over and then you learn so cycle
number four or five you know you kind of
figure it out and it might not be an
investment you want to hold all the time
but when it's good it's better than
anything and and I think people you know
are now dusting themselves off from you
know the 2021 dearle and getting back
involved now you know what they should
have done is read my LinkedIn post from
you know after Sam was arrested where I
was like this is the wrong price yeah so
another guy that sort of blew up the
world and um and and and you know it's
like seven out as they say on the CPS
table um but you know this this this is
coming back and I I just think this is
going to be a feature of crypto forever
and and and maybe one day we'll we'll
reach a point where nobody is a naysayer
nobody thinks it's worthless nobody says
it's backed by nothing and therefore
it's useless and it's you know just a
hot bed of CRI activity once you do not
hear that anymore we may well have
reached the terminal price but those
voices are still pretty loud and um and
that what that's what makes me you know
uh optimistic for the for the
future now my last question is uh if we
had talked five years ago maybe
definitely you know further back than
that and somebody said to me hey you
know who is Danny most of the
description of your career would have
been in the traditional Financial world
if not all of it yeah
when your career is done when you decide
hey I've had enough are you going to be
known as a crypto investor or as a
traditional markets investor and do you
see Pros or cons of either one of those
well I'm gonna I'm gonna reveal
something to you tonight PP and we'll
see what you want to do with it but um
so in July of this year I turned
60 and um I'm I feel like I'm very you
know young in body and young in mind but
the m is the math
okay and I went on a I went on a I want
to say it's like when you renovate your
house um I went to a clinic for two
weeks and I had every test known to man
and every therapy known to man I had a
nagging shoulder injury for a long time
you know I had um all kinds of stuff
done I may or may not have had uh a
little bit of face workk done we we
don't need to publish that too much but
I just wanted to I wanted to go okay
we're going to this has been the family
house we've been living in and we want
to live in it for a little bit longer so
uh so that's what we're going to do and
one of the things on my list was
something that um I promised uh Jean
Marie our CEO and my good friend um we
made some promises to each other back in
2014 and one of them was if Bitcoin ever
got to ,000 I would have a Bitcoin
tattoo and um and many years later um um
so that must have been uh you know nine
years later I delivered on the promise
and part of part of the part of the
thought process because I'm not a tattoo
gu as you can imagine but part of the
thought process was I wanted a kind of a
memorial to bitcoin and what it's done
for me and but that wasn't enough you
know when I thought it through I thought
that wasn't really enough and and what I
what I thought was you know this is
something I want to do for what Bitcoin
is going to do for me and for the world
going forward and that was a really
conscious Choice okay um I'll show it to
you if you want
yes no
way that is amazing how long have you
had that I had it ju
4 wow and I'm telling you something I
had to think long hard whether the
Bitcoin Market would rally because I
don't want to fall into the same trap as
noo Novo and you are gonna compare notes
in h in five or six years to see who
made the better tattoo choice I think
there's a long way to catch up but uh
anyway so so to answer your question and
that is the answer to the question I
think bitcoin's a magical thing I will I
will never cease being fascinated with
it you know I'm I kid you not when I say
obviously you know I have a lot of my
netw worth tied up in the company I have
a lot of network tied in you know some
liquid Investments 100% well 95% to do
with
crypto um and I can never get it right I
can never like get liquidity at a good
price in my stock to get me cash to buy
Bitcoin Because by the time bitcoin's up
you know it's it's a chicken an egg but
if at any point in time you know I I do
get meaningful liquidity for my rather
large position in coin shares um I am
seriously thinking about just become you
know I'm doing you know the ultimate
thing you know we know it's a store of
value we know it's a medium of exchange
but is it a unit of account I want to
make it a unit of account I want to and
there are some people that already do
that more the more the Maxis than than
the normal guys but I actually want to
do that because I really do believe in
it and um and that's as much as
believing in Bitcoin as disbelieving
feat but um but I I plan to do that
timately that's a fantastic answer I did
not expect that so that may be one of
the best answers we ever had U Dy where
can we send people to find you on the
internet or learn more about coin shares
if if they're intrigued by what you guys
are building and want to learn more sure
well uh you know uh DM at coin
shares.com uh or Danny LMS all letters
uh on
Twitter awesome well Danny thank you so
much for doing this you are a an
investing Legend and I think uh you've
been a Pioneer in Bitcoin
cryptocurrencies for a long time so
people are very excited to hear your
thoughts on where we are in the market
and we do this again in the future
awesome my friend keep well I look
forward to seeing you in the next time
hopefully hopefully had this discussion
uh at a big high price